do you think doing all the work that  you've done you know going back in time  you would have crashed me as many times  as you did  [Laughter]  since stopping things happen but yeah  three times in a week I know I know I  was a little aggressive for sure  um but you know usually when I crash my  friends it's only because I'm trying to  help but uh yeah I'm glad you just  dumped my primary car my back up and  then had to go to another backup for the  Daytona 500. that was what I was  planning too trust me the second one I  think it was during the duel when you  crashed I hadn't even thought about the  fact that like well she's got a race for  like she's not locked in she has to get  in and so I'm like oh no I'm just  praying the whole time that race is  going on I totally put out of my mind  what my result was going to be that day  I'm like please let her make the race  please let her make the race